Hey traders, it's Mike here and in this
video I'm going to address the question
that I got on one of my YouTube videos
about the order flow exhaustion entry
model and it's from
Sonal Tomar 9398.
It says, "Please share settings in the
next video."
Yeah, sure. Let's go over the settings.
Now, this is E-minis. Now, you know,
just really quick today in the E-minis
during the cash session there were
actually weren't any signals just going
back through here. There was a few nice
signals that took place before the
market before the cash market opened.
As you can see, you know, there was this
beautiful one that came in What time was
this? About 7:19.
A nice long here.
You know, it was kind of nice. You got
this nice strong delta coming in here
and then boom, you get
that reversal or sorry, that exhaustion
print causing the reversal, right? You
got nice stack buying imbalance, another
bunch of buying imbalances here and the
market jumped from about 55 all the way
up to 70 really quick over about 5
minutes. It was nice as strong selling
minus three minus 62 minus 217, but then
the sellers just hit the wall right here
and then they were done. You know,
basically that whatever aggressive
selling that took place over these three
bars
finished. It could only just trade
another 31 contracts and another nine
caused that exhaustion in the market,
right? And then it came back nice strong
positive delta and we jumped up about uh
you know, again from about 55 all the
way up into the 70 and even before that
there was a nice short. See this red
line shooting out across here at the
high of the day. This was at just after
6:00 a.m.
Okay, and
you know, on this high here right? We
got this nice and we even went down to
uh
you know, where we were earlier.
Um and again, you know, we're coming up
into the high nice positive delta 180
124. Then it's 24 63 24 just all
negative and we sell off. All right. So,
let's uh let's just talk really quick
about um the settings here. So,
on the Order Flows Trader, um
if you have the Order Flows Trader, it's
really easy to see this. I'll just go
through the settings really quick. If
you're using a regular footprint chart,
you could you could still see it. You
just got to use your uh basically just
use your eyes. Um what we're going to do
on the Order Flows Trader is you go to
uh exhaustion. You just find it here in
the settings.
Exhaustion prints, right? You enable it
and use the swing filter.
Um
and
you do swing and you're going to look
over the last 25 bars. So, it's got to
be a swing high over the last 25 bars.
And the volume limit, I use 10.
Okay?
Then we're going to draw out the green
and the red until tested. Now,
I got a couple other settings here.
Color opacity 20%. Um
and the size of the zone is just set to
one. Means one price level. But I like
to use 10 for all markets because I have
a
strong swing period. Okay? Now, if you
don't have my Order Flows Trader
software, you can get it. The link is
below in the description.
But if, you know, before I even
developed the Order Flows Trader
software, I used to just look for this
in the market on the normal footprint
chart. I mean, back in those days,
really you you know, this was uh 2013,
2012. Um we just had market delta was
the main one. Set with uh use CQG data
and the other one from NinjaTrader that
was available was the the Gomi the Gomi
uh one by by Gomi. I forget what it's
called now. Um
but this was the
exhaustion print, right? And again, you
know, today in the uh S&P's, there's not
many signals. Ultra bonds, nothing
today. There was a nice one yesterday
that came in kind of late in the day.
You can see it right here. I'll say late
in the day, but you know, after lunch
time 4:00 and we just continued rallying
to the close and even rallied all the
way up into today's session. That was in
the ultra bonds.
Euro currency was quite interesting.
Nothing late in the day, but early there
was there was a few signals here.
You know, there was the short
You want to look at this one. You know,
you don't know
just sort of did that. That was
around 7:00 p.m. Chicago time last
night, but during European hours we had
this nice exhaustion print
coming in here and it just sort of went
sideways before headed down, went back
up
back down again.
So again, not the biggest move, but you
know, still a move to be had there.
This was interesting.
I hate when this happens, but this is
how life is sometimes as a trader. You
get short off this exhaustion print
right here, comes up. If your stop is
just right here
you know, you get stopped out. Okay? If
your stop is one tick higher, you're
not.
And then we had this nice move down.
Okay? Now, just really quick. This is
interesting. Now, this is exhaustion
print one here. All right? The reason
why it's not showing because it's a
double top.
And when I have a double top with
exhaustion print I sort of treat it
differently in the sense that I have a
double top. So first time we trade 115,
second time we trade one. This is sort
of a different setup. It's still
exhaustion. Obviously the one the reason
why it's not giving a signal like you
have up here with the the red zone being
drawn out is because it is a double top.
All right? For a reversal using the pure
exhaustion print, it would have to be a
new high or a new low over the last 25
bars. This one obviously two bars ago,
it's the same high, but again, this is
why I talk about
if you're not using Order Flow Trader,
using your eyes. If you're just looking
at a normal footprint, you can identify
this as an exhaustion print, just as you
would here.
Okay, you know,
we got eyes. We can see the volume. It's
one contract. Just as over here, we can
see the volume is two contracts. I could
look to the left over here, and I can
see, yeah, that's these are coming in at
highs. Right? It's not coming in right
here. So, I I got to Is this a new high?
No, it's not. This is a clear high, you
know, just by simply looking to the
left. Just as this one is a double top.
And I just treat it sort of a different
setup, but it's a double
it's a double top with less volume on
the second test. Okay? And again, it's
it's also a nice move down. Um you know,
lately I've been talking to traders
about, you know, some of these other
markets like crude oil.
Crude oil is tricky cuz it's quite
volatile. I'm happy to see crude back in
the 80s, 89, though.
Um I'd rather see it at 81.
Um just to fill up my car, but
you know,
volatile moves,
volatile markets
is going to be tricky when you're
trading.
Um you know,
this one
stopped you out. These here I stopped
you out. This one, no trade here.
This one starts going up. Again, stopped
you out. That's something you have to
deal with on these volatile markets.
However, there's going to be trades, you
know,
this one
here. This one doesn't look like much,
but if you're getting long here, you
know, it's around 9028, trades all the
way up into, you know,
50 cents higher. This was a long here.
It just sort of went sideways. At some
point, you got to cut it for small a
loss rather than letting it stop you
out. Again, you know, this is a big bar.
You don't You know, even though your
stop would go down here, if it's
spending 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
10 minutes at break even and I got such
a wide stop here. I'm not going to wait
for it to come down here and stop me
out. If it's just If it's not moving,
it's not moving cuz this market is
volatile. I know you shouldn't see this
rather than a market going sideways
before it falling down and stopping you
out. Again, if you're looking for If
this is really true exhaustion,
what you want to see is that aggression
come in and the market start to rally.
Um let's see if there's anything else
here in crude. Sure there was.
This one, you know, even though it's a
nice move up, part of the exhaustion
entry model is it's got to take off this
high of the entry bar over the next one
and two bars. It hasn't, so there's no
trade here.
Okay?
Uh even though this was a nice one and
it did have a nice rally. Um it's it's
not following the rules of
entry. Okay?
Um we're getting back to about 8:30
this morning. Okay, there was this one
no trade cuz it didn't go any higher.
You know, but that's you know, 7:00 in
the morning. Now, mini Dow YM. Um we've
got one forming right here, actually.
This is a nice one. It's taking place
currently.
Um you know, while we're waiting on
that,
let's just take a look over here. This
was a nice This one failed.
Okay, so we got two trades here. One you
get stopped out on. The nice thing about
this one is your stop is pretty close
here.
Started go down and
but then it came right back up, stopped
you out. Then you get another signal
right here. And again, you know, you're
getting short here around uh
783.
Trades all the way down into the 40s.
Okay?
Um
is there anything else here?
Short here, also.
You know,
37 area, trades all the way down from,
you know, 35 this down to 80 in here.
Here's some stuff that, you know,
this is what happens in in more volatile
markets is you're going to get stopped
out a little bit more than you would
care to. That stopped you out, that
stopped you out.
Stopped you out.
Stop
out this one, no trade. Okay, but when
you're getting 40, 50, 60 ticks on the
winners, yeah, you could have a 10 tick,
you could have some 10 ticks.
Oh my gosh.
Thanks, I hate when NinjaTrader does
that. So it just bunches up on me like
that. Um
This one over here is a loser. This one,
again, is a nice winner. Doesn't look
like much, but
this is the one I'm talking about here.
This one is a loser. This one over here
started going up in your favor, got
about 20 ticks up. But this one is a
nice one. Again, this is what I'm
talking about, right? You're talking
getting long at 80, trades all the way
up
into the 30s, right? That's This is 50
ticks
right there.
Okay, just really quick, I'm curious
I haven't looked at it yet today the
E-mini. Oh wait, let's go back to uh
how that one is developing here. Okay,
so
still trading.
It's a little bit against us right now,
35.
We can be long from about 35, 36,
trading 26. I'm curious on the on the
eight range chart.
Any signals? Well,
I think there's just this one here.
Eight range also pretty quiet. I think
there's just that one.
Just going back to the cash open. This
one came up by a tick, took you out by a
tick, then reversed, but went down, had
a nice move down.
Again, if you want to use I just keep it
one tick, but you know, some traders
have messaged me saying I should they
prefer want to keep it a little bit
wider.
I would rather just get out on the one
tick than
you know, cuz then what? One tick
becomes two, two becomes three, three
becomes four.
Take the second chance entry or if it
just ticks you out by a tick, get short
again if it comes back down, especially
on range charts.
Um this one just sort of went sideways
for about 10 minutes before stopping you
out.
Um
but I I prefer to use time-based charts
rather than
tick base or sorry, range base because
this is what you often get where it's
going to tick you tick up a couple ticks
and then make the move in that
direction. Um how we looking
short on the second half of the day.
Yeah, nothing.
That was that one that we started out
at.
How's our mini doll shaping up? Okay,
well that one stopped you out. Again,
you know, fine, you know, you're getting
long at around 35 36, your stop is at
19 18.
Okay, fine, but in this market, I mean,
you're talking a move earlier from
here was our short.
You know, it's coming in around what?
81.
Down into the 30s, 35.
So, you know, that's about 45, close to
50 ticks right there. So, yeah, you lose
10 ticks, 12 ticks here, I think it was.
No, that's actually about 15.
You're long at 35, out at around 20.
But this one was, you know, 40 plus, 45
more or less.
All right, so that is the order flow
entry model. Okay, and again, just talk
about the settings really quick.
Come on.
I I use a swing period of 25, meaning
it's got to be a higher low over the
last 25 bars.
Um
exhaustion prints, these enable it, set
it to 10.
Right? That's it. That's all you got to
do. Um
again, if you if you interested in the
order flows trader software, I haven't
really talked about it a lot, but you
know, you guys come to my channel. You
It's called order flows, right? That's
my company, orderflows.com. Um the link
is in the description below. So, thanks
everyone, and I'll catch you guys later.
Take care.